그리고 저는 좀 놀라웠던게이 건축
비용을 약 600억 정도
투자를 했다라고 합니다
정말
엄청난 투자를 한 거죠 땅을 지금
568억에 샀는데 지금 건축비를
600억 정도 본 거예요
[음악]
네 제가 오늘은
2022년
한국
건축문화 대상을 받은 건물을 소개해
드리려고 합니다
청담동에 위치한 건물인데 여기 내려서
보면은
바로이 건물입니다
외관이
매우 웅장하죠 그래서
도산대로에 있는 건물이고
학동사거리랑 청담사거리 그 사이에
있습니다
외관은 이렇게 돼 있어요
지하 2층부터 1층까지 이렇게
뚫려 있습니다 이렇게 원형으로 뚫려
있고 저도 방금 갔다 왔는데 예전에
그 스페인 건물 보러 갔을 때 유럽에
온 느낌을 좀 많이 받았습니다 그래서
이게 어찌됐든 강남이 엄청 비싼
땅값인데 안 그래도 지금 건축 제한이
너무 많은데 이렇게 공간 활용을 한
사례는 좀 처음 봤거든 강남에
이렇게까지 예술적으로 만들어 놓은
건물은 저도 처음 봤습니다 여기
밑에서 이렇게 위를 보면서 정말
놀랬습니다 지금 소문 빌딩이 작년에
대상을 다 탔어요 강남구 그 건축
대장도 받고 그래서 저도 갔다 왔는데
왜 받았는지 알 것 같습니다이 건물에
일단 저는 어찌됐든 빌딩
투자 누군가니까 뭐 내부도 중요하지만
약간 투자 관점에서 좀 간단하게 좀
분석 좀 해드리겠습니다 지금 소유는
송은 문화재단 그래서 제가 보니까
비영리 법인이고
일반인들한테도 다 이제 공개를
하시더라고요 여기에 뭔가 신인 작가들
그런 분들이 전시를 하거나 그런 되게
좀 의미 있는 공간이라고 생각하고
저는 어찌됐든이 되게 비싼 강남
청담동에이 땅에 저런 공간을 만들어서
저는 신인 작가들한테 저런 제공을
한다는 그리고 일반인들한테도 저런
공간을 보여준다라는게 굉장히 좀 높게
평가합니다 정확히 빌딩명은
st
송은빌딩입니다 두 법인이 이렇게
2분의 1씩 가지고 있고 이제이
빌딩은
2016년도 16년도에
568억에 매입했습니다 그래서 그
매입했을 당시의 모습을 좀 볼게요
그래서 원래 이제 매입하기 전의
모습이
이거였습니다 그래서 자동차 전시관이
들어가 있는 그런 건물이었어요 근데
이거를
568억에 매입했습니다
재단에서
요게 돼지가 357평이에요
그러면
평당 1억 6천 정도
싸게 매입했죠
2012년도에 그 건너편에
삼성생명에서 2명 것도 평당 뭐 1억
중반대 막 샀거든요 그래서 그때
기준으로 했을 때 물론 이제
2016년부터 쭉 올랐어요
근데 그때 당시에도이 가격이면 굉장히
잘 샀습니다 그때 당시에 저도 이제
근무를 하고 있었지만
굉장히 좋은 매물이었어요 지금 시세는
한 두 배 정도 되는 거 같아요 한
3억 정도 그냥 땅값만 최소 3억은
넘지 않을까 이렇게 예상을 합니다
그게 제가 항상 말씀드리지만 위치가
좋은 건물은 그냥 계속 오릅니다
어찌됐든 돈에 가치가 계속 떨어지고
그리고 공급이 한정되어 있잖아요
청담동 땅을 다시 또 늘릴 수도
없잖아요 그리고요 위치 자체가 워낙
좋아요 제가 제일 좋아하는
도로가 부산대로인데
도산대로 중에서도
진짜 좋은 도로입니다
청담동에 위치한 그 도로고
로데오 그쪽 블럭을
물고 있어서 여기가 이제 그
신세계에서 또 많이 샀거든요 분더샵
있는 쪽 그리고 명품 거리도
삼성가에서 좀 많이 샀고
큼지막한 업체들이 좀 많이 사는
곳이에요 그 중에 이제 도산대로가
좋거든요 제 그래서
강남 중에서도 위치가 정말 좋은
위치다 이렇게 보시면 될 것 같습니다
그리고 여기가 일단은 그
노선상업지에요
노선상업지여서 가중평균에서 신축을
해야 되는 건물이었고 그래서 이게
용적률이 한 370% 정도 370%
정도 밖에 못 받았습니다 그래서 원래
일반상업지가
800% 3종 250%
해서 가정평균을 하니까
용적률을 그렇게
높게 받지 못했어요
2017년도에
2017년 2월 달에 착수를 해서
설계만 20개월이 걸렸습니다
시공이 34개월
정도 걸렸어요 그래서 토탈
56개월이 걸린 프로젝트입니다
지하
5층에
지상 11층 건물이에요 그리고이 건물
설계는
굉장히 유명한 그 건축사 사무소에서
했거든요 설계는
스위스에서 헤르조쿠와 피에르
르메롱
어려운데이 두 분이서 설계를 한
거예요 그래서 한국에서 처음 최초로
하는 그 설계의 작품이고이 두 분이
그 전에 중국에서 베이징 올림픽 그
경기장을 또 했다 그러더라고요 그리고
홍콩에서 한 작품도 있고이 스위스에서
좀 굉장히 유명한
건축가라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다
그래서 일단은 외관을 좀 보면은 좀
창이 많이 없어요 여기는 좀 이렇게
막아놨는데 이게 그 노출 콘크리트인데
약간 그 소나무의 느낌이나요 그래서
저도 아까 이렇게 만져보니까 되게
신기하더라구요 그 송은 그 재단
자체가 뜻이 이런 나무와 좀 관련이
있다라고 좀
들었었거든요 그래서 그거를
토대로 이렇게 외관을 한 거 같고 그
다음에 여기 창은이 높이가 13m래요
그래서 국내에서 제일
긴
창이라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다
그래서
3m면 한
4층 5층 정도 되는 그 정도
높이라고 보시면 될 것 같아요 한
3M 정도가 한계층이니까 한 4 5층
정도 되는
큰 유리 그러니까 국내에서 제일
높은 그런 유리를 여기다가 이렇게 해
놓은 겁니다 건축비가 굉장히 많이
나왔을 것 같아요 이거를 또
가져오기도 좀 쉽지 않고 지하도 좀
들어가는데
진짜 무슨 호텔 로비 같았어요 그래서
약간 그 등 자체가 되게 은은하고
뭔가 호텔에 온 느낌이었습니다 그리고
제가 그 이렇게 건축사님 이렇게
인터뷰한 것 좀 봤는데 일단 이분이
했던게
처음에 주변 건물들을 많이
봤대요 주변 건물들 많이 보니까
재료가 너무 너무 가지각색인 거예요
이분이 신기했던게
무슨 일조권 사선도 받고 일조권 사선
때문에 지금 건물이 이렇게 된
거거든요 그래서 일조권 4선도 있고
뭔가 그 용적률도 제한이 있고
여러 가지 되게 제한이 있다는 거
일단 놀랬대요
창문을 좀 최소화한 거는
옆 건 좀 조화를 많이 생각했대요
뒤에 쪽에 창문을 낸 거는 그 테라스
부분이 주거와 이렇게 좀
연결이 되게 이렇게 설계를
했다라고 좀 하시더라고요 미술관
자체가
단순하게 그런 작품만 보는게 아니라
그런 공간과 좀 어울러지는 것을 좀
많이 생각을 했대요 그래서 저도
딱 그
입구 들어가자마자 일단은 밖에 이렇게
창이 크게 나 있었어요 그래서 거기
이제 좀 조경도 돼 있고 바깥 안을
좀
연결하려는게 좀 보여줬고 그 다음에
또 재밌었던 거는 바로 들어가자마자
이제 지하 2층까지 이렇게
뻥 뚫려 있어요
뚫려 있는 공간 옆으로 나선형 계단이
있거든요 그거 계단을 오르면서 이렇게
밑에를 보는 그런 느낌이 좀 있었어요
되게 좀 색달랐어요 일반적인 건물과
다르게 그래서 그 계단을 올라가면
스크린 볼 수 있는
약간 강의장처럼
그렇게 돼 있는 공간이고 그 위에
층은 이제 전시 미술관이긴 하지만
공간이
외부랑
연결되게끔 좀 많이 신경을 쓰신 것
같아요 그리고 저는 좀 놀라웠던게이
건축 비용을 약 600억 정도
투자를 했다라고 합니다
정말
엄청난 투자를 한 거죠 땅을 지금
568억에 샀는데 지금 건축비를
600억 정도 본 거예요
토탈이 재단에서 굉장히 좀 신경을
많이 쓴 그런 건물이고 이거는 사실
뭐 부동산 가치 이런 걸 떠나서
한국에서 되게 좀 사회에 좀
뭔가
기부를 한듯한 그런 느낌이에요
뭔가 엄청 비싼 위치에 이런 공간을
진짜 비용 많이 들여서
투자를 했는데
일반인들한테도 이렇게 공개를 하고
제가 봤을 때 외국인 관광객들도 좀
많이 올 것 같거든요
맨날 외관만 보다가 지나가서 그냥
보기만 하다가 오늘 내부 가서 보니까
아 정말 이런 건축물들이
한국이 좀 많이 생겨났으면 좋겠다
이런 생각을 좀 많이 했고 일반적으로
생각하는 저희가 그런
단순하게 그 용적률만 채워서 만든
공간 이런 건물 보다는
한국을 알릴 수 있는 이런 좀
건축물들이 많이 나왔으면 좋겠습니다
그래서 좀 되게
느낀 것도 많고 되게 배운 것도 많고
그래서 여러분들도 만약에 시간이
되신다라고 하면은 여기 이제 예약하면
갈 수 있거든요 누구나 다 가능합니다
그래서 예약을 미리 하신 다음에 제가
말씀드린 공간을 한번 직접 눈으로
보셨으면 좋겠어요 좀 많이 느끼시고
하셨으면 좋겠습니다